antonin nouvian secrétaire générale du
mnr le mouvement nationaliste entre bien
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors c'est une étape
cruciale qui s'est achevée à minuit
celle des choix sur parcours sup la
plateforme a été plébiscité par beaucoup
de jeunes une bonne nouvelle dans un
contexte si particulier
eh ben pas tant que ça il ya beaucoup
aussi de nos camarades qui sont
extrêmement inquiet du fonctionnement de
parcours sup
nous on a des résultats similaires à
lenquête que vous avez que vous avez
évoquées nous aussi on a mené une
enquête auprès des lycéens on a près de
70 % des lycéens qui sont inquiets pour
leur avenir c'est un chiffre très
préoccupant donc effectivement on ne
sait pas si les lycéens sont satisfaits
actuellement du système parcours sud
d'autant plus que j'ai certains de mes
camarades qui m'ont fait part de
problèmes avec la plateforme
j'ai une camarade sur angers par exemple
qu'il ya des tiers des problèmes des
bugs de sectorisation elle est sur
angers mais elle peut pas postuler dans
sa propre académie elle par contre elle
peut sur les académies par exemple de
marseille
donc on est tous dans l'incompréhension
sur un fonctionnement qui est quand même
assez opaque
nous on est plus qu'inquiets sur le
fonctionnement actuel de parcours sup et
on est plus qu'inquiets sur les
résultats alors concernant le choix des
étudiants on a vu que que cette année a
été complètement bouleversée comme on
l'a dit par la crise sanitaire les
universités qui était fermée on a
l'impression que
les écoles les grandes écoles l arrivée
à suivre plus les cours en tout cas ce
que le choix des futurs étudiants ont
plutôt été dirigée justement vers les
écoles plutôt que les universités ben le
problème avec les universités c'est
qu'il ya de moins en moins de place nous
on demande d ouverture massive de place
donc aujourd'hui c'est clair que les
lycéens peuvent difficilement postuler
dans les universités alors qu'ils savent
que ils ont des chances d'être refusée
et même quand bien même il y arriverait
ils vont être probablement pouvoir ils
ne vont pas pouvoir étudier dans de
bonnes conditions
donc effectivement il ya certains
lycéens qui se tourner vers les grandes
écoles plus que vers les universités
vous nous avez parlé des conséquences
psychologiques de cette crise sanitaire
beaucoup d'étudiants qui sont démotivés
qui ont réellement peur pour leur avenir
c'est le fait de ne pas pouvoir se
projeter qui les inquiète effectivement
c'est clair que beaucoup de nos
canassons perdu on dit dans un monde
assez compliquée avec les problèmes
globaux comme la pandémie comme la
pandémie ou comme ou comme le
réchauffement climatique
mais ne serait-ce que les problèmes que
rencontrent déjà les lycéens qui sont de
futurs étudiants
ça inquiète énormément il ne sait pas
quelle place on aura dans le monde de
demain
les étudiants qui ont également beaucoup
de mal cette année à payer leur loyer à
s'alimenter beaucoup ont eu recours aux
distribution des aides alimentaires quel
regard portez-vous sur cette situation
j'ai pas mal de camarades effectivement
avec lesquels j'ai pu parler des
camarades étudiants qui sont dans des
situations assez compliqué j'ai même eu
un camarade qui a dû qui a dû pendant
pendant plusieurs mois l'an passé
n'avait pas de n'avait pas de logement
effectivement les étudiants sont dans
une situation extrêmement précaire
et c'est quelque chose que je trouve
très inquiétant pour les futurs lycéens
pour les futures études nous sommes on
sait que fin novembre l'éducation
nationale a annoncé la création de 20000
emplois étudiants supplémentaires pour
des missions de tutorat le doublement
des aides d'urgence aussi à tous les
étudiants est ce que le ministère a tenu
ses promesses en la matière ben nous on
n'a pas vu les retombées encore
donc je ne peux pas confirmer ce travail
qui alla supposément été fait par le
ministère moi je n'ai rien lu beaucoup
ont dit se sentir oubliés la jeunesse en
tout cas on s'est créé également de
nombreux suicides d'étudiants depuis le
début de l'année beaucoup de
manifestations également pour déplorer
les conditions de vie est-ce que selon
vous il ya une indifférence des des
responsables politiques justement sur le
sort des étudiants
c'est terrible et on répond toujours
l'impression qu'on ne répond toujours à
côté qu'on veut pas discuter avec les
véritables organisations étudiantes on a
vu le gouvernement recevoir des
influenceurs plutôt que de recevoir des
responsables syndicaux étudiants qui eux
ont véritablement
connaissent le terrain connaissent
connaissent les problématiques
on voit que le gouvernement n'essaye pas
véritablement de d'interroger les
étudiants et 2 et de répondre à leurs
problématiques mais il essaye de faire
de la com est-il des mobilisations
prévues dans les prochains jours de la
part des des étudiants des futurs
bacheliers de la part de toute la
jeunesse le 16 mars notamment on va se
réunir dans plusieurs villes notamment
sur paris pour pour les notamment les
jeunes travailleurs les étudiants et les
lycéens on se réunira pour pour demander
à être écoutés parce que effectivement
aujourd'hui on a on est extrêmement
inquiet pour notre ami antonin nouvian
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire générale du mnr le mouvement
nationaliste